et en parallèle de ces auditions menées
au parlement il ya donc cette
information judiciaire pour abstention
de combattre un sinistre elle a été
ouverte en juillet par la cour de
justice de la république à l'origine de
la plante et donc des perquisitions les
derniers jours le collectif de soignant
ses 19 représenté par l'avocat fabrice
di vizio
il est en ligne avec nos bonjour et
merci d'être en direct sur rtl
qu'est ce que vous attendez de
l'audition d'edouard philippe par les
députés sur quels sujets serez vous a
particulièrement attentifs cet après
midi à vélo mettre d'accord je n'attends
rien de la commission d enquête
parlementaire je le dis depuis le
premier jour cette commission d'enquêté
parlementaire plus particulièrement à
l'assemblée est un entre soi et rien
d'autre premier élément deuxième élément
cette commission denquête siège en toute
illégalité la constituent pas des
redevances de 58 prévoit effectivement
très commission d enquête parlementaire
qu'elles sont dessaisis lorsqu'une
information judiciaire est ouverte on ne
peut pas avoir une information
judiciaire pénale et une commission
enquête parlementaire sur les mêmes
faits donc aujourd'hui en toute
illégalité
la commission d enquête parlementaire
poursuit ses travaux
donc qu'est-ce que j'en attends rien je
place ma confiance dont les
perquisitions qui ont eu lieu je place
ma confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire qui est réellement
indépendante
mais cette commission d enquête
parlementaire fait de l'entre- soit
comme je l'aï dit je n'en attends rien
vous craignez que les auditions à
l'assemblée nationale ne percute
finalement les les l'information
judiciaire qui a été ouverte
je ne fais pas si elles vont répercuter
mais nécessairement et c'est bien pour
ça d'ailleurs que le législateur avait
prévu qu on ne pige pas avoir une
enquête judiciaire et une enquête
parlementaire sur les mêmes faits la
priorité est donnée à l'enquêté
judiciaire parce que là l'autorité vie
ici avec indépendante
mais alors ce que j'attends si je devais
attend quelque chose de cette commission
enquête cet après midi il ya une chose
que j'attends c'est que monsieur
philippe frenette la copie des mails que
madame du lundi lui avoir envoyé et qui
reconnaît avoir reçu qu il a reconnu
avoir reçu sa salle unique à salo débat
la question de la gestion des stocks et
tout ce qu'on veut s'ils ont envie
effectivement de faire un débat
là-dessus qu'il le fasse entrer mais la
vérité elle est simple que savez
monsieur philippe
lorsque l'épidémie s'est déclenchée et
que je les appelle et comme un homme
bizarre lui at elle écrit je sais que ça
comme question et c'est bien la question
qu'on ne lui posera pas parce que
finalement monsieur philippe si l'apport
de répondre ne répondra pas et les
tenues à rien et donc c'est là où on
voit que leur enquête judiciaire est
nécessaire les perquisitions ont eu lieu
les ordinateurs ont été saisis on aura
la teneur de ces mails
le reste c'est de la littérature et de
la mauvaise littérature avec une
assemblée qui n'a rien d'autre à faire
aujourd'hui dans un tel contexte
polémique que venir donner l'impression
que elle fait un travail d'enquêté pas
un travail banque est elle fait rien du
tout généreux elle aurait déjà demandé à
copiner bègles et en formation c'est un
problème
l'information judiciaire à laquelle vous
êtes à l'origine on le rappelle vous
avez déposé plainte en mars comme ça me
déjà en octobre plusieurs perquisitions
menées ces derniers jours c'est un
rythme très rapide c'est un rythme
soutenu effectivement les qu'une justice
qui tend à envoyer un signal
relativement fort qui devient c'est pas
parce qu'on est ministre que pour autant
on est une sur catégorie citoyens et qu'
il y à une impériosité à venir actionner
le système judiciaire rapidement à venir
avoir des réponses rapidement et que en
l'occurrence effectivement les
perquisitions en plein mois d'octobre
eh ben c'est un bon signal qui est
envoyé et c'est pour ça que cette
commission d enquête est une mascarade
parce que une semaine après que la
justice ait posé un acte fort de
perquisition voilà que celle fille tout
à coup se réveille et vient
effectivement dire qu'elle va
auditionner monsieur philippe mais
quelle valeur pour avoir cette audition
si l'on considère aujourd'hui tout est
entre les mains de la justice
les ordinateurs les téléphones entre les
mains a g6 book pilotable la politique
politicienne
ils vont s'arracher les vêtements
surligner commencer tellement bien faire
dans cette république mais il en sortira
rien que parce que les membres ou ex
membre du gouvernement et qu'espérez
vous finalement quelle est la visée du
du collectif de soignants que vous
représentez alors que nous espérons est
ce que nous souhaitons c'est ce que nous
demandons c'est la vérité je le répète
car exactement dit madame plus un
monsieur qui dit madame busin est la
seule ministre de la santé d'europe
peut-être même du monde à venir
expliquer qu'elle savait
qu'elle a averti les autorités qui n'ont
que faire de leurs dossiers d'artistes
mans elle a dit avoir
nous voulons le contenu de ces mails
c'est aussi bête que ça
j'ai envie de dire ensuite quant à
savoir ce qu'ils risquent il risque deux
ans d'emprisonnement et une amende par
ailleurs et surtout effectivement s'il y
conte avec laurent fabius a contaminé
c'est finalement une mise entre
parenthèses la politique salue cela il
dira que ça lui a coûté l'élection
présidentielle quel impact est ce que ça
peut avoir sur la gestion de l'actuel
nouvelle vague de colis de 19 c'est une
bonne question
le premier un pas que rien à la ghana il
ya un double impact
le premier c'est qu'on a forcément une
tentation de se dire on va déployer le
parapluie on aurait pu le penser
on aurait pu penser que grâce à cette
seconde vague on le répète lui et le
parapluie de peur effectivement de
l'institution judiciaire
mais finalement on s'aperçoit que nous
sommes en permanence encore dans un
rythme d'un décision absolument
épouvantable dans un demi mesure avec un
gouvernement qui évite à des
contradictions flagrantes
ici un couvre-feu vous l'avez vu dans le
reportage couler tout à l'heure
mentionnée
on la recouvre chaud ici mais tiger on
va avancer à 19 heures dans les grandes
villes
enfin à côté de ça on a effectivement
mis de la culture qui dit qu'il faut que
le cinéma et la culture soient épargnés
c'est du n'importe quoi parce que nous
sommes face à un gouvernement incapable
qui n'a absolument pas pris la mesure de
la crise parce que je le redis avec
puissance
nous n'avons pas de gouvernement nous
allons y administration de la santé mais
en aucun cas un gouvernement je le dis
depuis le premier jour et je le répète
avec force nous avons affaire à un
gouvernement de pryor et jon que terme
merci on comprend votre mécontentement
les termes que vous employez évidemment
n'engage que vous fabrice division
avocat du collectif de soignants à 7 19